so
first question i have for you is even
after leading your own tv show was there
anything about headlining a
gigantic disney feature film that kind
of took you by surprise uh
yes a hundred percent i mean still
everything that happens to me regarding
you know
work and filming stuff like blows my
mind
it never feels real you know i i love
acting so much because of
you know the art of it you know and like
like connecting with people that you've
never even met through a screen
like that's always been what's drawn me
to
acting into this industry and so then
when
i haven't even really thought about it
and all of a sudden like it's my face on
a poster
or something like that it just like
completely blows my mind
um so yes a hundred percent i have those
what is my life moments pretty much
every day
um and it's it's really
crazy it's because you earned them and
deserve them
oh thank you so one of my absolute
favorite
parts of the movie is the snowflake
speech and this is a little bit of a
of a deep heavy question but with that
in mind
what is something about yourself that
maybe you once
viewed as a flaw or imperfection and
then
came to realize that's what made you
special yeah well i think
um honestly i connected with sam a lot
from the very beginning from the very
first time i read the script because
we both have this natural instinct to
want to do things ourselves and to be
super independent
and i think that characteristic
can be both good and bad you know it's
great to be independent
it's great to want to do things by
yourself but in a sense it sort of
distances you from other people
sometimes you know and when you're not
asking for help when you're not
um sort of pulling people into your life
into your life you can feel um alone
you know so i think that's definitely
something that i
see in myself that i see in sam um and
that
is both um a great strength and can feel
like a weakness
you know depending on how you use it on
how it sort of
um how it sort of comes out you know
um and sort of that journey of
figuring out how to use all these
characteristics you have and sort of
channel them into something positive
and getting all of the good things out
of them rather than the bad things
um or the not bad but more difficult
things um
and that's something that i've
definitely experienced and i think sam
has ex
same experiences throughout the movie um
so that's definitely something that i
would say is a
great strength and also um flaw if um
if sort of used in the wrong way or if
it if
it comes out in the wrong in the wrong
way i can certainly understand that
so yet another part of the movie that i
absolutely loved was just
the ensemble everybody is fantastic in
it so
i got a couple of questions pertaining
to the rest of the ensemble for you so
just tell me who who is the answer to
the question and maybe a little bit why
so first who would you say is the most
like their character in the movie
i would say the great thing about this
film is that everyone is so much like
their character
in a lot of ways you know um
like art really imitates life in that
sense and it really became very
apparent to me when i had met all of
them and then when they were playing
their characters because obviously
you know isabella um has a lot of
similarities to january and also some
not
and um and you know we we all do
i feel like tuma's strength is really
reflected
in niles and you know vice versa um
matteo and folly are a lot of alike in
that they're both very quirky
they're both very funny um olivia
and um roxanna i feel like i think
they're pretty similar
in that like they just have this great
big open heart
you know and and again i've sort of
explained to you how i'm similar to my
character
but yeah i wouldn't say there's one
person that's um more similar to their
characters than anyone else
um but i would say we all definitely
have a lot of similarities to our
characters which is what i think
makes sort of the acting and the whole
thing so um authentic
i'll squeeze in one more here if you
could swap roles with anyone in the
movie who would you pick and why
ooh i think i would have to pick skyler
who plays james
i think he's such a funny character like
the
the lines he has the things he says are
so funny
and also when he like duplicates himself
and he has like a bunch of him like i
feel like that would be really fun to
sort of like
pick a personality for each of the
different copies of yourself which he
kind of got to do which i which i
watched and was like
really impressed by and really i it
looked really fun to me so
probably his character kind of want him
to get a whole spin-off movie now so i
could see more of that
i mean secret society too
huge congratulations thanks so much for
your time today
of course really nice to meet you